hey everyone this is the gtx 970 the
classic msi gaming version astonishing
performance for its time it could beat
the 780 ti and overclock beyond stock
980 performance what a card and this
this is the gtx 1070 the reference
version here a bit pricier than its
predecessor but it delivered performance
on par or better than the titan x
maxwell now this is the legacy that the
new rtx 2017 needs to live up to but to
what extent can it deliver that's the
question i'm answering today or at least
attempting to answer you see the problem
with reviewing any rtx products in the
here and now is exactly the same as it
was when we looked at the 2080 and the
2080 ti there's a ton of new tech in
these gpus but little to no software
that uses them outside of some demos so
take rate facing for example now at the
rtx launch event we did actually get to
see some early demos and games running
on 2080 ti hardware so at least there
was
some idea of performance targets and
whatnot but the 2070 only offers around
60 percent of the rate-facing power of
the 2080 ti so we're kind of left in the
dark here about how real-life
performance is going to shape up though
battlefield 5's recommended specs
include the 2070s so maybe we'll be okay
but right now we don't know
dlss though nvidia's extraordinary
upscaling technology well we can at
least benchmark that and the specs look
impressive
and it kind of needs to be impressive
because in common with the rtx 2080
standard 3d performance is actually
closely matched to the last gen nvidia
card that's one lung higher on the stack
so the rtx 2080 is very similar in frame
rate terms to the 1080 ti while the
2070. yeah as expected it's close to the
1080p but in other ways this new 70
series card is very different from its
predecessors it's not a cut down rtx
2080 in the way that the 1070 was a
paired back 1080 it's actually based on
a whole new chip
tu106 and this offers around 78
of the cuda cores of the 20 80 and 75
percent of its rate facing power but
there are some commonalities between
2070 and 2080 where actually no cutbacks
have been made at all there's still a
256-bit memory interface and both cards
deliver a prodigious
448 gigabytes per second of memory
bandwidth and as you can see from the
specs
during well it still has that cuda core
deficit against pascal if we're
comparing 2017 to 1080 at least but the
new architecture is considerably more
efficient with vastly improved memory
caching at the silicon level so the card
we were sent for review
is the remarkable msi gaming z8g version
of the rtx 2070.
it's a bit of a monster in pretty much
every single way now it's big it's heavy
has a custom pcb high quality materials
throughout and an accomplished cooler
the tu-106 chip isn't that much smaller
than 1080 tis about 445 square
millimeters versus 471 so a good cooling
solution is needed especially when this
version of the card comes with a
remarkable 210 megahertz factory
overclock more on that in a bit ports
wise we get the same three display ports
and hdri 2.0 as the founders edition
plus the usbc virtual link
the fe card only requires one 8-pin
power input but for this one yup you
guessed it there's an extra six pin
input even with that big factory oc in
place this rtx 2070 sits below 70
degrees celsius under load but whether
it's the best 2070 to buy well pricing
is the thing really but it's the
performance that's more the thing right
okay so for most of my benchmarks i've
detuned the gaming z here to founders
edition clocks to ensure parity with my
other founders edition benchmarks and
also as a ton of 2070s on the market do
actually come already with some kind of
mild oc out of the box but to begin with
i'm going to take a look at dlss
performance because this is going to be
a key touring technology and the impact
could be particularly profound on the
rtx 2070 so let's begin with final
fantasy xv here with the 2070 stacked up
against 1080 and 1080 ti performance out
of the box comparing standard taa
rendering the 2070 already beats the
1080 by an above average 13 percent but
looking at dlss
there's a 37 improvement to performance
which in turn offers a 21 boost over gtx
1080 ti running the same content in the
epic infield fader demo 2070s apples to
apples lead over 1080 extends to a
somewhat unlikely 18 but dlss adds an
additional 42 percent of performance
giving it a 32 boost over 1080 ti
okay so there may be some shenanigans
here with regards to turing versus
pascal comparisons but if we're looking
at dlss delivering a 35 to 40
improvement something we see in both
demos well the potential here is
remarkable
and an important takeaway here is that
dlss boosts are actually pretty uniform
across all rtx cards the 2070 might have
a lower spec and fewer of the deep
learning tensor cores but it has the
horsepower to run dlss at full pelt
nvidia has accrued plenty of support for
dlss already which we will be looking at
in time but i do think that these demo
numbers are credible dlss at 4k
essentially works by using deep learning
to upscale a 1440p image and when you
think of it like that the performance
boost is pretty much entirely in line
with you know what you should expect so
that's where 2070 could be a real game
changer in comparison to 1080 and
potentially even 1080 ti
what is a great performer in the here
and now for 1440p gaming is transformed
into a card that can handle 4k
as well if not better than 1080 ti
so let's move on to standard
rasterization performance and here i do
feel that 1440p is the baseline
resolution you should use this card for
like the 1080 before it so all of my
benchmarks are running with an i7 8700k
with a 4.7 gigahertz all-core turbo and
i've got 16 gigs of 3400 megahertz ddr4
looking at this benchmark here stacking
up 2070 performance between 1080p 1440p
and 4k resolution you can see that even
with this mighty cpu there are areas
where 1080p and 1440p graph lines get
remarkably close and can even bisect if
a 2070 runs at the same frame rate in
these areas at 1080p and 1440p
you can reasonably assume that the cpu
is your limit here despite the vast
amount of power we've thrown at the
problem there but let's dig into one of
my favorite legacy games first of all
assassin's creed unity it'll set the
stage for many of the benches to follow
in that the rtx 2070 has a small lead
over the 1080 but remember that we are
on founders edition clocks here so that
six point lead would likely diminish to
around half that at reference the rtx
2080 is 25 percent faster while 2080 ti
delivers a mighty
extra 50 percent of performance
battlefield 1 yeah even on a
two-year-old game the frostbite engine
is still pretty forward-looking so
performance is almost 11 percent better
than the 1080. the 2080 offers an 18
point lead while 2080 ti continues to
dominate with a 45 performance boost
it is interesting to see though that the
2070 is punching a little over its
weight there eating into the lead of the
higher end cards compared to our ac
unity results
back into legacy territory with another
one of my classic benches crysis 3
there's a small three-point lead over
the gtx 1080 here which vanishes
completely at reference clocks there's
an extra 22 percent of frame rate on the
rtx 2080 rising to a phenomenal 55 on
2080 ti
i mean if dlss could work on more games
the 2070s equivalent performance level
here would be between those two
higher-end offerings which really does
make you think how much of a
game-changer dlss could be if more
comprehensively implemented next up the
havic assault on gpu resources that is
ghost recon wildland running at ultra
settings a mere six point lead here for
the 2070 over 1080 and yeah once again
reference clocks would have that lead
i've not plotted the data here but the
2070 is actually 14 faster than vega in
this bench rtx 2080 has a 19 point lead
over the 2070 which rises to 40 with the
mighty 2080 ti a tale of two tomb
raiders next as we study gpu performance
on both rise in the tomb raider and its
sequel the recently released shadow
both run on crystal dynamics foundation
engine but one tends to slightly favor
last gen pascal cards while the other
favors during
well with rise once again rtx 2070
offers a tiny perf bump over gtx 1080
which you guessed it evaporates if
you're on reference clocks scaling to
rtx 2080 only delivers an extra 16
percent of performance which perhaps
explains why 1080 ti can outperform the
2080 but there's a decent 45
booster performance with the rtx 2080 ti
which you know it's just in a class of
its own
so shadow sees an 11 point lead for the
2070 compared to the 1080 and in turn
the 2080 delivers a 20
uplifting performance over the 2017 2080
ti an extra 50 percent now as you may
have guessed by now that's fairly
indicative of the differentials
generally in rasterization performance
across the rtx line and it does
demonstrate that the 2070 offers the
best frame rate to price ratio
judged by msrps the rtx 2080 is 40
percent more expensive than the 2070 but
only delivers 20 to 25 more performance
meanwhile the 2080 ti boosts frame rates
by around 50
but has a 100 price premium okay so i'm
going to round off the performance
numbers with a couple more titles
yes we're returning to novi grad city in
the witcher 3 where founders to founders
rtx 2070 is a remarkable 17 faster than
gtx 1080. the 2070 actually seems to be
the sweet spot for this title the 2080
is only 14 percent faster while 2080 ti
clocks in with a 43 boost and for the
record the 2070 is actually 20 faster
than vega 64 here remarkable stuff
finally wolfenstein 2 the new colossus
all of our benchmarks derived using fcat
a video capture based benchmarking
system that ensures accuracy by actually
measuring the frames that come out of
the gpu unfortunately artifacts on the
border there at lower resolution stop
the monitoring system from working
correctly at lower resolutions meaning
we need to do this one at 4k where the
fcat data remains intact
it's a 10 improvement from 1080 to 2070
but this game actually shines much
brighter on the higher end rtx offerings
kind of like the opposite to the witcher
there's a straight 30 boost of
performance going from 2017 to 2080 and
the 2080 ti is actually 60 faster than
the 2017. right so i've concentrated on
founders edition clocks for the most
part in this review but there are some
really decent reference cards there at
msrp like the msi armor for example and
then at the other end you have cards
like the gaming z here which have a
monstrous factory overclock so there's a
spectrum of performance across the range
of offerings and this leads to some
fascinating results so in my next set of
benchmarks i've got 1080 and 1080 ti
compared with the 2070 but reference and
gaming z clocks and doubtless you can
see how all of that pans out here so
we've been looking at crysis 3 here as a
legacy title no real differences between
2070 and 1080 while the gaming z offers
up an eight-point lead with its mammoth
megahertz factory overclock gtx 1080 ti
though sits pretty at about 16 percent
faster than the gaming z
however if you look at other titles the
situation here becomes a little less
clear-cut in shadow of the tomb raider
and remember this does favor turing
hardware the reference 2070 is seven
percent faster than the reference 1080
and once again the gaming z's factory
overclock gives it an 8 point lead but
the gtx 1080 ti's lead now drops to
around 10
the gaming z can probably stand to
overclock a little bit further and we've
not even touched the memory clocks here
on top of that reviews of the msi armor
version have seen performance match and
slightly exceed the gaming z if you
manually overclock so yeah there's a lot
of grey area here for tweakers to
explore
oh and remember that big turing boost in
the witcher 3 well even at reference
clocks the 2070 has a 13 performance
advantage over the 1080 while the gaming
z factory overclocked version of the
card offers
96 of the performance of the gtx 1080 ti
which is quite remarkable the situation
is even more fascinating with
battlefield 1 which also has a nice
turing advantage the reference 2070 has
a 7 lead over the 1080 while the gaming
z version sees the gtx 1080 ti's
dominance reduced to a mere 1.7
lead i mean we're approaching margin of
error stuff here
so it's kind of curious really certain
game engines really like the turing
architecture and with a range of factory
overclocked cars in the market plus the
potential to overclock yourself of
course there's a spectrum of
differentials that kind of make pegging
down the 2070 in terms of pascal
performance terms just a little bit more
challenging right then well let's wrap
this up i don't think rtx 2070 has the
immediate impact the immediate appeal
that 1070 and 970 had back in the past
and you know let's make no bones about
it the tu-106 chip is bigger more
advanced and costlier to produce and the
memory is more expensive too and so we
are looking at gtx 1080 money for a
product that in many situations only
offers gtx 1080 performance some might
say that in rasterization terms it's a
side step and you know what well maybe
we should just wait a while just to see
how raid face performance stacks up and
to see just how much of a game changer
dlss is gonna be
personally i do feel the momentum is
there to see these new features being
utilized maybe at that point we start to
feel some of the 70 line magic arrive
with turing okay so i'm going to wrap
things up then please do like and
subscribe to support the work we do here
at digital foundry ring the bell for
instant notifications whenever a new df
video drops and yeah do consider the df
patreon to support the team more
directly and to get access to pristine
quality video downloads but that's all
from me for now thanks for making it all
the way to the end of this one if indeed
you did but from me for now thanks for
watching